from above along the river wire policing
search for a body
they received a call just before midday
from dog walkers who noticed something
or someone in the water
an underwater search team and specialist
officers entered the river it wasn't
long before they resurfaced and
recovered a body in a statement
Lancashire police said no formal
identification has yet been carried out
so we are unable to say whether this is
Nicola bully at this time procedures to
identify the body are ongoing we are
currently treating the death as
unexplained but it was Nicola bully a
mum of two who more than three weeks ago
vanished whilst walking her dog Willow
after dropping her children off at
school she took her normal route and
even though she was seen twice a crucial
10-minute window remains unaccounted for
it was 23 days ago Nicola Bully's phone
her dog Willow and its harness were
found right here police have said all
along they don't believe she left this
area and their focus and working
hypothesis is that she entered the water
how and why is still unclear
the search for the 45 year old has been
extensive divers underwater drones and
even boats out at Sea over the last week
search efforts which were focused
Downstream had significantly reduced
it's been a major operation that has
stunned a quiet rural Village in
Lancashire
Alice lives near to where the body was
discovered she says whoever it is it's
the saddest of days for this Village
it's just so scary I mean it's it's fact
it's so close to home and I mean we're
such like a
I say like a safe little village but you
know and nothing like this has ever
happened especially not in my lifetime
and I mean the whole Community is just
gobsmacked gobsmacked really it's not
been nice it's not been nice and just
driving like we drive through it every
day and seeing all the police everywhere
it's not normal for us you know we'd be
lucky if we saw a police car in six
months never mind
every day this will be the most
difficult of times for Nicholas family
their ordeal has spanned three long
weeks and even though hope has never
been in short supply here this latest
development will test everyone full of
promise
foreign
oh my heart goes out to the family this
evening
yeah it does uh and I've been in contact
with them
tonight and look you know police haven't
yet identified uh
who that body is that they recovered
earlier today but Nicola bully went
missing over three weeks ago for a
family it has been an absolute roller
coaster this last three weeks because
not only
has a mom a partner a daughter A Sister
Gone Missing
but there has been huge amounts of
attention on this case the nation's eyes
have been drawn to this very small this
quiet this quaint Village in rural
Lancashire